each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my pleasure to welcome makita
answer to Microsoft so mäkelä is
associate professor at the University of
lugano in switzerland where he reads the
review group which is short for reverse
engineering visualization and software
evolution evolution and the analysis one
last and miquelon soft on many pcs he
was PC chair of many conferences like
for example for ms our conference which
is actually not from Microsoft Research
Conference but for conference on mining
software repositories and next year his
pc co-chair of ICS m2010 in romania so
miss McGee thanks so good thanks for
having here and let's start with a
little prologue about myself so my name
is Tom already said is Mikael Atlanta
I'm Italian so I was born and grew up in
Italy and moved around a quarter of a
century go to Switzerland where I did a
PhD at the end at university of bern and
then in 2004 i moved to lugano that's
really as beautiful as that picture well
it's also boring town noteworthy things
about me are maybe this thing so I wrote
a book together with Radha marine high
school on metrics I'm actually fairly
proud of the book I also call it two and
a half years of blood and sweat and
another thing which is not worried about
me is that I'm actually a small talker
so all the things we do is are actually
written in small talk so Tom said in
Uganda way I leave a research group
whose research interests revolve around
three main domains so I have currently
one post Oakland and six PhD students so
i will not really mention two of the
seven topics here because these ph
decisions just start this year and i
will focus mostly on immersive soft
visualization for this talk but feel
free to talk to me about any other of
those things there
so just to give you a brief introduction
to this so one of the things we do is
called fine-grained soft revolution that
work was done by Homer hop in the
meantime he has become a PhD so a doctor
so the things we did there was basically
to observe the versioning systems as
mainstream versioning systems are
basically not sufficient when it comes
to modeling software evolution because
basically there are snapshot based so
they are based on when somebody wants to
commit to the repository and because of
this if somebody doesn't commit four
hours or days it means that you
basically lose a lot of information so
what we did in this case was to develop
a system called spyware which we
presented it eggsy last year which
basically tracks every single change
that happens in the system as it happens
and then we refi those changes first
class objects and we couldn't we can do
several things with those changes so for
example we used it to enhance a code
completion engine by an order of
magnitude in terms of precision or for
example we one of the things we also did
was basically that you can take a set of
changes and of course these changes are
hard-coded in a sense on the system on
which they have been applied and you can
abstract them away and basically create
custom refactorings on the fly so this
is fairly interesting where another work
is better done by Mitchell ungol he's
about to get his ph.d next month here
basically we started in Reverse
architecting software systems and at a
certain point in time we thought that we
actually have to go one level higher
which we call software ecosystems which
is basically the set of software systems
as they leave as they live together in a
certain organization so for example
sourceforge can be considered a software
ecosystem so we have developed for this
a web-based tool platform which allows
us to analyze hundreds of software
systems as they live together and like
this you can for example track
developers how they move from one
project to the other what kind of
relationships projects have with each
other how active people
r during which time and so on another
axis of work is done by marcos ambrose
this is on bug analysis in prediction
where we again developed a tool platform
and we have developed a couple of
different approaches to first of all
analyze software box in the sense that
software bugs are have a lifetime they
are born and then they live or coal live
together with the system for a certain
time until they are closed down or still
remain in the system this is another
work done by Lily hattori this is
basically continuation of the work by
Homer hub where we basically took the
spyware based approach to another
language because spyware was built in
small talk in this case we work on Java
which has a lot of implications because
Java is a file based language and
because of that it's actually not so
easy to extract changes as they happen
so basically developed a tool plugin for
Eclipse which can capture the changes as
they happen and then we lose several
things with them and this is also in the
context of collaborative software
engineering so basically the point here
is to not only track changes as they
happen but as they happen in a
collaborative context so when several
people were in parallel on the same
system and then we developed mechanism
for example of notifying people if
something happens at the same time that
somebody is changing the system in this
talk I we mostly focus on the work of
Richard Vettel which is about immersive
of the visualization so I named the talk
seeing software so first of all I should
explain what seeing is all about now
seeing of course is understanding and we
are visual beings so seventy percent
percent of all brain inputs come through
the eyes in reality we actually see with
our brain we don't really see with the
eyes and there are three types of memory
that process visual information there's
iconic memory which is like a register
short-term memory which is a working
memory and long-term memory now and
won't go into long-term memory because
this is more psychology than anything
else
now what iconic and short-term memory so
iconic memory is basically a buffer that
retains information for less than one
second before it passes it on to the
short-term memory and perception in this
case is limited to a very limited set of
attributes perception is very fast it's
automatic subconscious and because of
this it's called also pre-attentive
perception then there's also short-term
memory where the information is
processed in the in the form of chunks
and perception again is temporary that's
a couple of seconds and in case the
information is not rehearsed by the
brain it usually goes lost and it also
has limited capacity so that's three to
nine chunks depending on on your brain
basically and if you add another chunk
to short our memory basically one of the
chunks will fall out this for example
explains why charts are more expressive
than tables because if you look at the
chart basically the brain chunks the
whole information that is presented to
it and then can suck in the information
better while if you look at the table
basically have to read the table and
this just takes longer now I will focus
on pre-attentive processing attributes
and just to give you a couple of
examples now these are pre-attentive
attributes a form which are very
relevant for soft realization so what I
will show now is a couple of very simple
diagrams and what will happen is that
there's always one element which is
different from the others and your brain
will process that the fact that one of
the elements is different before you can
actually react so for example as
orientation there's line length there's
line with their size or shape Earth's
curvature or edit marks there's
enclosure these are just now the
attributes of form there's also
attributes of color of motion and so on
now if you apply this to software let's
just start with something which is very
simple and probably this is the most
simple visualization you can have of
software so you have an entity in a
software system like a class and you
just displayed as a box of course
systems are composed of more than one
class so
maybe you have a second class and if
they have relation together you can draw
an edge between them that's just a very
simple application of pre-attentive
processing attributes if you now apply
this on a real system you obtain
something like this now this is a very
small software system that's classes and
inheritance relationships and you can
already start now to interpret what you
see so you see for example there's two
inheritance hierarchies in the system
there's a couple of classes that are
standalone one of the hierarchy is
actually larger and if you look at the
larger hierarchy you see that it has sub
hierarchies as well as well for example
this one or this one now what you can do
with this of course is fairly limited
now if you just use a very simple idea
called poly metric views you just enrich
now this simple visualization with a
couple of software metrics so imagine it
for example for the width of a node you
use the number of attributes for the
height of an old you use the number of
methods and for the color from white to
black you use the lines of code so this
makes you go from here to here so that's
the same system now enriched with
metrics and now what you can start doing
is interpreting what you actually see so
of course you may think that well let's
focus first of all on on the big stuff
or on the dark stuff but that's not
really the point so of course one of the
things that strikes the eye is an
element like that which means it's a
class it has a lot of methods it's very
dark which means it has a lot of lines
of code now if you compare it with this
class here that class actually has even
more methods but it's lighter which
means that the black guy here has longer
methods in average or other things that
I see is putting things in a context for
example if you look at this sub
hierarchy here now classes in a
hierarchy usually they are related to
each other otherwise they wouldn't be
siblings in a hierarchy so for example
here you see that this class is way
larger than its siblings and it means
that there is something noteworthy about
this class compared to its context now
if you scale this up you obtain
something like this so this for example
is our go UML that's 120
130 k lock system written in Java it's a
uml modeling tool and here now you can
start interpret what you see so one of
the things that really strikes the eye
of course is this thing here that Clause
of course that's an older version of
argument that class was called model
facade so it's a facade pepper and it
has an incredible number of methods an
incredible number of attributes and is
around five thousand lines of code long
which is abnormal compared to the rest
of the system so I'm not saying that
it's abnormal to have such a big class
but it's abnormal to have it so big in
its context because the rest of the
system is more or less well balanced
actually what what happens with this
class here so this is a lot class is
that developers of argue ml basically
pushed any piece of functionality that
they were not really sure where they
should put it they pushed it inside that
class so the class over time grows like
a cancer in the system actually with
what then happened later on is that they
reflected the class and I will show a
couple visualizations about this as well
so other things you can see for example
our particular hierarchies where there's
one superclass and then dozens of
subclasses and if you look the subclass
for example are all very similar in
terms of raw number of methods and you
should go and have a look there you will
see that a lot of code is duplicated now
of course this is just a picture so one
of the things that you need to do if you
have such pictures is to interact with
them so like 10 years ago I wrote a tool
called coke roller which was fairly
famous in the meantime we have rewritten
it as an eclipse plugin called x-ray and
this basically is integrated inside
eclipse so if you click on a class here
basically get to the code if you click
on the code you get to the visualization
and so on and you can navigate back and
forth so this is a first part on seeing
the second part is software because the
talk is called seeing software so if you
look at the definition of software
according to wikipedia software is the
soft parts of a computer system
and it's the intangible object inside
the computer now if you ask any
developer what software really is
usually the answer will be that software
is basically composed of text now if
source code is text then what follows is
that programming is writing that's also
what general Weinberg said in the
psychology of computer programming is
that programming is some kind of writing
which I actually disagree with because
30 years ago it was like that in the
meantime we're in the 21st century so I
in way things should change but they
still didn't change and what you get is
for example things like that this is the
world's smallest chess program it's
actually a working program it's 133
lines of code of C and it's actually
working chess program but I think this
just goes a little bit too far now this
is all about people being used to
certain things so of course you learn
programming by opening opening up a text
editor and then you write text inside
your compile the source code and obtain
running program now in the rain
remainder of this talk i would like to
basically fight a little bit this notion
so let's talk about seeing software now
the first thing i have to do is of
course define soft realisation so that's
the definition according to john stasko
which in my opinion is way too long so
let's make it a little bit shorter so
soft realizations the use of computer
graphics to facilitate the understanding
of software so soft realizations for
sure is not this okay so this comes
actually from the obfuscated at sea
contest so this is a a runnable program
written in C it's just formatted in a
funny way now visualization is depicting
things so one of the sentences that you
often encounter is this that the picture
is worth a thousand words I actually
also think that this is wrong because
it's not about talking randomly about
things visualization most of all is
about stories if you have a
visualization and you can talk about it
in a meaningful way then it means that
visualization
is useful so maybe the for me greatest
example of them the visualization that
is actually a story is this thing here
what is depicted here is the campaign of
napoleon to Russia so you see here on
the right side the army leaves the thing
is wide because there were lots of
people at the beginning there were four
hundred and twenty-two thousand soldiers
so as they march towards east and as you
see it was very cold during that year
people start dying ok so there's also
some people that branch off at a certain
moment and as they go on they die more
and more of course because they didn't
have the right shoes and so on and as
you see for example when they encounter
a river that the fame also reduces
itself suddenly in size because crossing
the river back then was really hard so
in the end when they arrived finally at
Moscow there were only 100,000 soldiers
left which of course was not enough to
conquer Moscow and what happen is that
they basically retreated and try to get
back to France and this was done a real
catastrophe and as day as they go back
in the end 10,000 people got back so
four hundred and ten thousand people
died now that's for me a beautiful
example for visualization another thing
which often shows up you only talk about
visualization is UML so this now the
question is is this soft little ization
well in my opinion you mmm uml basically
took the thing with a thousand words to
literally because to interpret such a
diagram you need to talk way too much
and the point of view ml is not really
that the point of your mail is to
describe design and is to discuss design
and in a way it succeeded at doing that
it's really a universal language if you
give this diagram to programmer in
Brazil or in China or in Europe all of
them will be able to interpret this
software visualization has one problem
which I actually call balls dilemma and
that is that software
intangible because it has no physical
shape or size so how can you possibly
visualize something that has no
equivalent in reality now I think that
you can basically solve balls dilemma by
using metaphors so a couple of years ago
I read a very nice book by Richard
Gabriel called patterns of software and
in that book he calls he talks about
this concept of habitability which is
the feeling that you get when you are
inside a software system looking at the
code and you feel cozy in a way because
you're confident about the code and it's
easy to change it now if you take this a
little bit further and that's what we
did basically we try to visualize
software systems or cities how do you do
that well first of all you have to have
a domain mapping so we met classes on
buildings in the city we met packages
for districts and then the whole system
is one city we enrich this again with
metrics for example in this case number
of methods it represents the height of
the building and number of attributes
represents the base size and if you
apply this on a larger system you get
something like this now this is again
argh EML that's another version a later
version actually this is a transitional
version so the large class from before
is here and what they did as a first
transition was to create a new class
called NS uml model facade and what they
started doing was basically copy over
source code from one class to the other
and that's actually that's the Twain now
now you may wonder ok so so what do we
do with this now there's a couple of
applications that we used the first one
is large-scale program comprehension the
second one is evolution analysis and the
third one is displaying software defects
or software problems now just about
large-scale program comprehension I
don't really have the time to go and
reverse-engineer a full system one of
the things i will do now is just show
you some kind of Hall of Fame
after systems so again this is our guy
UML now this is a really recent version
this is from like two months ago so you
see the system in the meantime is
growing as well so it's 167 k it nearly
has 3,000 classes and what you can do
now with this is look at the patterns
inside the system so one of the patterns
is the thing we call parking lots so
this or this parking lots are basically
classes which have very few methods
that's why they are not really high they
are not tall but they have a lot of
attributes so this one here of this one
here so basically these are data classes
that they just define hundreds of
attributes and then that's what the
class is used for or you have this
office buildings so these are classes
which are large both in terms of number
of methods and in terms of number of
attributes so these are potential god
classes in the system then you also have
have this antenna like buildings there
these antennas are classes which have a
lot of methods but basically no
attributes so actually in this case
since this is Java these are interfaces
in the system so we just define hundreds
of methods and then they are reused by
the other classes so let's just look at
a couple of systems and you will see
that across systems there's patterns
that you can identify so this for
example is Apache cocoon 4,000 classes a
little bit larger than our be UML here
for example you see that compared to our
guy UML the functionality of the system
is better distributed among the classes
there's no real large outlier of course
these classes here are large but it's
not a real outlier in that sense another
one even largest system nearly 6,000
classes is frostwire this is going to
Java system so here you see that the
patterns are completely different and
you also see other patterns for example
these things here so these are little
houses where people live in okay so it's
very small classes so for example
plugins or packages containing plugins
often look like that next one even
larger is this one here
little bit that one is over 10,000
classes and you see that nearly the
whole system is is well balanced in
terms of functionality distribution but
there's a couple of outliers here like
this year or those over there what this
also allows you to spot our fundamental
problem something like this now this is
called open swing it has actually a lot
of classes but it's just one class here
which is humongous liebig yeah actually
if you rotated you see some of the other
classes but you see there's some some
major problem in here or the inverse
problem this is Apache b-cell you have
humongously big data container and then
another one which is also very very
large and it's not that these systems a
few classes this one for example is 550
classes this one thing can even be worse
than this for example disease hsqldb
that's a 160,000 lines of code system
and they just define some very large
data containers scaling up a little bit
discourse already towards the half a
million lines of code is his views
that's a famous bittorrent client here
we see that's for example for me the
definition of a nice system or a
beautiful system if you actually cross
the language boundary you also see that
systems written in different languages
actually look different so this for
example is in C++ and C++ systems how we
always have this strange shape that
there are there's a couple of humongous
buildings and then scattered smaller
buildings or for example is on here is
June that's an OpenGL application it's
written in small talk and again you see
that the pattern of the whole system is
different we also but we also can do is
multi-language visualization of systems
so this is now ten systems written in
Java small talk and C++ and regarding
scalability also did a couple of tests
so now this is nearly 1.3 million lines
of code and of course this is a tool so
it means that
it's not just a picture you can fly
inside rotate it do things with it
colorize things and so on if there is
time at the end it will also give a
little demo on this now that's the first
application another thing we did with
this is to apply this on software
evolution and the goal here is to
understand software evolution so the
first thing you can do is create film
strips so here for example you see ten
snapshots of our UML from 2002 to 2007
and you see here the the rise and fall
of model facade in 2002 model facade was
not around then in 2003 it showed up and
then it grew very very fast into 2004
and then it was refactored so there was
then they created the interface out of
that class which then was called facade
and then there was also an S uml model
facade and there was also an
implementation of this and in the end
this fixed slowly shrinks so what they
did basically was a major overhaul of
the system and I think they were pretty
successful at doing that so they've got
rid basically of a cancer in the system
one of the things you can also do is
create movies so this for example in
animation of jamo over the course of
eight years every frame that you see
represents a bi-monthly snapshot so what
you see here this is an application to
model molecules in 3d at the beginning
the system is fairly small there they
are doing little work on it then at a
certain moment they start expanding the
system at more and more classes and at
one moment they do a a major overhaul of
the architecture they copy over
basically they create new packages and
start creating copying functionality
over to the rest of the system and what
happens towards the end is that the
system grows in an abnormal way so here
I think things got slightly out of hand
here
okay and again you see something like
that just humongously large okay one of
the things you can also do is to use
color to represent the age of software
artifacts in a system that what we call
the H map so this is now again arg a uml
and what you see here is again the whole
system the lighter the things are in the
system the newer they are so the the
more recent they have been changed so
for example you see here that there is a
class called Java recognizer in Java
token types so it's an obvious office
building with the corresponding parking
lot and they also have the C++
equivalent of that called VP parser and
STD see token types and you see that c++
part of our vml came later okay we
actually yes when you do this
illusionary diagrams how you keep those
certifications
the same building two here in the same
spot as we basically do not model
classes but we model classes is class
histories so basically we look at the
whole evolution of the system and then
we assign to each class history its
position in the system by taking into
account its maximum size during the
evolution and then that one is like the
place it uses yes first exactly this
also means that with time there's the
empty spaces in the system because they
were abandoned we actually can push this
also one level down regarding
granularity so in this case we represent
classes just as the the base of such
buildings and each cube here now is a
method in the system and we again
combine this with them with the age of
methods in this case and you see again
different patterns coming up for example
this whole package here is brand new
compared to the rest of the system
there's also classes which look like
this so there's a bunch of methods which
is really old and then they add more
methods in your more recent version and
so on so both these for example our
classes which are all being changed
constantly while something like this is
just very new and then you have
buildings like that which has been the
same all the time so they were created
once and then they remain like this I
can also show a little animation of this
so here we start with in two thousand
the system is called Jo draw then in two
thousand one of course things get a
little bit older than September 2001
march two thousand two august 2002 and
you see the patterns when enough fat is
removed from the building basically
create an empty space so you really see
the buildings get fragmented and i think
it's also a nice way of depicting decay
in a sense then in 2003 the system gets
older but they still work on certain
things and then suddenly there's a whole
package which shows up at once this
package here is actually called test so
they edit all tests at once so
we thought like well it's the time span
with basically half a year so did you
really take them half a year to add the
test in reality no it took them like two
days so if you look at the history in
two days they added all this so then
when we talked to developer about this
he said that basically these are all
generated test cases and they are empty
so these are all methods which are empty
basically so that's why it was easy to
create them all at once and it looks
good of course if the system is tested
and then we go to january 2004 another
application is how to display design
problems in the system so here we use
the metaphor of disease maps where you
use a gray color for the things which
are not affected by problems and other
colors for the things which are affected
so this for example is jdk 1.5 all the
blue buildings here are God classes
that's the same view from above you can
also look push this down to method level
so this is now j mol and all the methods
which are yellow are affected by feature
and v which in this case is around the
quarter of the system i think it's a
nice way to display this it really looks
like it's pervading the system this is
just the sub part of our UML the model
package and in this case we display
methods which suffer from shotgun
surgery okay with respect a tool support
we built all this inside a tool called
code city it's a multi-platform tool
because it's written in small talk so
it's also released for windows and in
the meantime we have quite a number of
download but i guess i can give a very
short demo on this
ok
so this basically the configuration
panel of code city and what you can do
now is you can take one system and you
can say okay I would like to have a look
at the city in this case now it's argue
Mel dot 0 23 for now it's building the
whole visual model and in the end it
renders the figures and that's what you
obtain so now what you can do in here is
first of all you can get closer you can
move around you can rotate the whole
thing and you can also click on things
get information about them like metrics
and so on if in case you have the source
code just in parallel to the model you
can also directly jump to the source
code and just look at the source code
itself so things you can do here now is
first of all navigate around you can
colorize things so you can basically
take them with colors and then the color
i edit through the model of the system
so that if you open it later on you can
get back to those colors one of the
things you can also do is display design
problems for example let's have a look
at the god classes in the system and
here you see for example this one here
is a God class what I would like to know
now is with whom this God class is
related I can display now relationships
for example inheritance location and
access I can use a nice yellow color for
this I can accept this
let's see this may take some time
because it's a god cloth so it's heavily
connected and of course there's also
Murphy around right which is always
around let's just try again so this is
let's just five that ok
let's try also this okay so now this
works so here for example now you see
all inheritance incoming and outgoing
relationships of this class i can add
now the invocations to it and you see
it's quite connected inside the system
one of the things i can also do is I can
for example display just the more
fine-grained view like this ok now we do
this on the system called I text I guess
it's some kind of text editor written in
Java rendering the figures take slightly
longer because there's just more things
to be rendered the system is not
optimized at all by the way and that's
what you obtain and now again you can
get closer and you can inspect things
and so on so in this case for example i
can now color eyes for example brain
methods or methods affected by feature
andy and so on and you see the system is
does have quite a number of problems one
of the things i can also do is look at
the evolution of things so in this case
we have eight version of patro and i can
look now at gear valving city this will
now take a little bit time because it
needs to create eight models visual
models of junior otra which is not a
small system
well maybe I should not do that on the
fine-grained one because this may take
even longer let's just load the usual
course going on okay and let's try that
let's see
okay so now you obtain a little player
here which makes you go back and forth
in time so now you can just go back in
time and see how the system changes over
time so you see this now was the test
package which is disappeared because I'm
traveling back in time okay I guess
that's good enough for the demo let me
quickly come to the conclusion of this
with a couple of reflections first one
is that soft whistle ization if you
think about this a good means to make
the intangible tangible I think if you
if you use the right metaphors and most
of all you if you make the whole thing
interactive because I don't think that
you can generate a magical picture of
the system but you need to generate
pictures which tell you things and then
they need to be interactive so you can
basically talk with the pictures as well
then this can really bring a lot of
benefits it's actually not so difficult
after all so visualization is based on a
very few simple attributes that mostly
concerned the way that our brain works
it's still in its infancy so although
there has been soft realization research
for the last 20 30 years I think that
only in the 21st century computer
systems have become powerful enough to
display things as the ones i have shown
you and most of all i think it's an
exciting research area so where do we go
from here so one of the things that we
are currently doing is how to display
relationship so you've seen before
during the demo little appetizer on this
but there's different ways to display
relationships one that we are currently
looking at is that the relationships
actually create the layout of the system
so if things are well connected then
they should be central and so on this
actually leads to a number of
computationally problematic problems so
if you have a system with hundreds of
thousands of relationships which is
normal
and then all of those should basically
dictate the layout of the city then you
need very powerful computers so this is
one of the things we've done so far with
bundled edges and another thing that I
am mostly interested in is to obtain
hyper realistic things so of course the
cities I've shown you were very simple
and in the meantime we've gone to higher
quality graphics so one of the things I
would like to do in the future is to
have the notion of augmented reality
because right now the interfaces I've
shown you in cults it is actually still
pretty clumsy because if you click on
things then the information is displayed
somehow on the side and then you already
have a disconnect or it would be better
if you would display superimposed on top
of the 3d reality that you see here but
this is coming and this basically ends
my talk thank you very much yes further
ends
just like other attributes like in
relations as it sets or presentable
gross you're not taking
yeah the roads have been actually the
relationships that would dictate to him
but I know it's hard yes but are there
any other things you can do use this
metaphor that
no I think that metaphors are are just
metaphors that can only go a certain way
so I know the work of one guy called
Thomas panas he actually took this a
little bit further by having trees
inside the city and people walking
around and cars driving by but in
reality I don't think this makes much
sense because in a software system there
are no trees seguin example the entire
city could be white or black yeah
depending on how much code coverage you
have particular pieces of Talia's
particular rhythm piece of cordage hour
eighty percent of the time dat person to
the building is painted this is things
we've already done but for example one
of the other things we've done is a use
color to denote who's working and we're
so activity of programmers and then
animate is full time and this actually
is very telling but the problem is that
i don't really talk about it here
because it's hard to get things like
that published I also have to say that
last year for example I was at the
developer conference and I showed a
preliminary version of this work and
developers were enthusiastic they were
like wow this is great but then you go
to scientific conference and people
offered you that's just the way it is
what about studies on the relative
value of something like this embed do
something much more mundane like you
know start sticking reports hit very
languages
so that's actually something that we've
been I've been doing the last half year
so we started to basically read all the
papers which are on empirical studies
with human subjects because you need
human subjects or something like that
and in the meantime we are arriving more
or less to a conclusion on how to
perform actually such a study and one of
the fingers I found funky was that I've
been told for the past many years like
are you should just look at the
empirical work on this on how to
overwrite visualizations there's lots of
work but in reality should go and look
at this basic no real work so one of the
things that I've learned in the mean
times that if you compare something like
this then you have to compare it to
something and the question is what is
the baseline so naively one good thing
while the baseline for example is the
IDE so you give for example one software
system to somebody and just have a
couple of tasks to perform and half of
the people have this and half of the
people just have Eclipse for example now
in reality this is not this doesn't
really work so one of the things I've
learned in the meantime is that the
thing you have to do is that the tool is
actually the Delta so the two groups get
exactly the same things so all of them
get the same amount of information get
also eclipse and so on and then one
group gets on top of all of that the
system and they can freely choose
whether they want to use it or not and
then you can measure if they can answer
or perform tasks faster and better than
the others and that's the only thing
that you can really do but we are slowly
coming to this yes we do there with your
hands or
or on your side's at some particular
thing and you put a text label or this
this part was this was a big test
directory and the reason you know that
is because of words I mean there's the
names of things yep are very important
to program works and it feels really
missing from from these visualizations
and just being able to point at
something and see on inside panel or
intuitive or something turns it into a
game of concentration so any thoughts
about how you would integrate so one of
the one experiment we've done is
actually to use textures on the
buildings and also on the packages and
so on and that the textures actually
display the name of things but I also
had to learn there that you can do it
too naive way and it's just the created
texture and put it on the building the
problem then is if you rotate the
building what happens if the texture so
I've seen that in the information
visualization community there's a lot of
people that actually are doing things
like that for example if you if you have
free deep map of a real city and the
roads you see the names of the roads
then as you move around actually the
names also move around so something like
that I think the solution in this for
such a problem is really augment the
notion of augmented reality that if I am
looking at something around my field of
vision I get additional information on
top of that and if you think about it
for example there have been people doing
research with eye tracking devices it
actually shouldn't be that difficult
because of course one thing is the point
with the mouse the other thing is just
to look around so you look you rotate
your head and then the eye tracking
mechanism actually knows where you're
looking at and then you just display
augmented reality information
that I've wondered about the the 2d plan
the city the kind of
the top down God's eye view is there any
sense to what Smith's to what or the
spatial layout or is it just can it
happens it's an excellent question so
the the layout algorithm we're using
right now is simple rectangle packing
algorithm so it tries to pack as many
rectangles as possible in in a surface
and this actually ignores the
relationships because for example if you
have 50 classes in one package and one
of those classes is connected to all the
others then logically this class should
be in the middle of the district and
then all the others around it or for
example if a class is mostly talking oh
okay
Naruto beanie and I looked at
people drawing code on the whiteboard
they didn't put the highly connected
stuff and know they they would we'll
talk about this later we need that but
basically there's a vertical axis for
the layer cake the traditional kind of
you know top to the be why the bottom is
the fitting and then they strike
functionality
to line up across those things where to
play hopefully I've got stuff the other
the other comment about put the
connected stuff in the middle that's
kind of the traditional force where I
could lay out doing and my friends who
knew graph layout for a living
the schedule of some of these faults i'm
not sure but what they found is that
this is not how people do graph layout
what you end up with is a big ransom
instrumental and this halo of outliers
what makes more sense according to them
is to put the highly connected things
have the corners and that way that will
kind of get the gravitational attractors
so you don't in other words you don't
put the headquarters for boeing
starbucks microsoft and costco in the
same you know you don't put it next to
each other you spread them out so that
you don't get kind of everybody trying
to live well but so certain extent then
the position is for sure indicated also
buy them to which this to which package
they belong so I doubted Boeing and
Microsoft are in the same part of the
city because they just need more space
the other thing in this context yeah no
that's that's a really nice suggestion
another thing I would like to do is
actually that you can place your
buildings or you want so it gives you an
initial layout but then I can modify it
because I think this class should just
move over there because it's not it's
like the UI part and then I can move it
slightly out and then the system should
remember that but currently this is not
possible I mean we could implement it
fairly easily of course but again how do
you publish or something like that yes
to visualize where there might be a
tremendous amount
of development effort like where are
people working at any given time in the
city yeah I'm wondering about a
visualization of dependency in part of
your shipper release is dependent on
many groups finishing together and
reflection of the dependency as they
move towards release date or shifting is
there a way to show dependency or any
kind of threat or risk and it groups and
their dependencies on each other over
time wow it's a tough one sorry I guess
one of the things I always want to do it
but we never got to it is of course if
you if you have people working on a
certain class then you can work and
colorize that class according to the
color of those people but one of the
things you could also do is that the
people are not mapped on on the
building's themselves but around the
buildings kind of in in free space and I
guess with something like that you could
you could do something that you would
see the efforts of people as they move
around in the city something like that
you're a manager who is very concerned
about your ability to get these
dependent groups to complete together
for any test cycle that you're going to
go through all to be a relief that you
want to see as soon as possible that a
reliance or a dependency is going to get
your ability to get to that that ship
date and if you can see it 60 days
would you move resources like you can
start to make management decisions and
because you show this idea of going back
in time I don't know if you can forecast
or go ahead in time that you can
certainly see at any given time the
state of the dependencies and start to
forecast or predict or have a sense of
the risk or absolutely the problem the
problem i have in this case is that I
never had a scenario like that so it's
if you give me the data then i can think
of solutions traffic
might help you because you might see
that some extreme evolves into the
freeway and it gets bigger and bigger
time so you can sort of projected oh
we're adding more work and sings along
the same path
projected
it'll just going to your ball
or so things on fire
the towering fertilization have you
thought about displaying then I make
information about execution yeah we've
done that so what you do basically some
I don't have a picture right now where I
can dig it up later so basically one of
things we do there is basically switch
off the light and everything goes dark
so it's like the night and then we put
switch on the light in the buildings
which are active at a certain moment
during the trace so you see basically
how the activity goes from one part of
the system to the other and then you can
also use the edges on top of that it's
actually funky nice question
okay thanks